.
Die Erkältungssaison
geht jetzt erst richtig los.
Das bedeutet:
Aber hilft Vitamin C
wirklich gegen Erkältung?
Nicht immer, ob ihr euch
mit Vitamin C etwas Gutes tut,
oder ob ihr es gleich lassen könnt,
das klären wir jetzt.
Willkommen bei MaiLab,
Freunde der Sonne.
Ich bins wieder, Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Und das ist Linus Pauling ein viel
größerer Chemiker des Vertrauens.
Zweifacher Nobelpreisträger,
1954 für Chemie, und 1963
der Friedensnobelpreis, weil er sich
gegen Atomwaffentests einsetzte.
1970 brachte ein Buch
heraus mit dem Namen:
"Vitamin C and the common cold".
Er war davon überzeugt, dass
Vitamin C gegen Erkältungen hilft.
Ungefähr so überzeugt,
wie viele von uns es heute sind,
mit ihm ging
die ganze Vitamin C-Hype-Welle los,
die bis heute nicht abgeflacht ist.
Normalerweise braucht man
pro Tag 90-110 mg Vitamin C.
Denn Vitamin C ist wichtig, u.a. für
verschiedene Stoffwechselprozesse,
es ist auch ein Antioxidans,
hierzulande hat man
eigentlich keinen Vitamin C-Mangel.
Trotzdem kann man im Drogeriemarkt
Vitamin C-Tabletten kaufen.
Mit Dosen von 200 mg aufwärts,
teilweise sehr viel aufwärts.
Denn viel Vitamin C
hilft ja gegen Erkältungen.
Das sagte ja auch
schon Linus Pauling.
Aber auch Chemikern des Vertrauens
darf man nicht immer vertrauen,
denn selbst die Chemiker
können auch mal irren.
Bzw. die Wissenschaft kann irren,
weil gerade medizinische
Zusammenhänge so kompliziert sind,
dass man viele Studien
und viele Ergebnisse braucht,
bis sich ein klares Bild
zusammenfügt.
Weil medizinische Studien
so verwirrend sind,
gibt es die sogenannte
"Cochrane Collaboration".
Ein intern.,unabhängiges Netzwerk
von Wissenschaftlern und Ärzten.
Die schauen sich zu einem
bestimmten Thema möglichst viele
medizinische Studien an, bewerten
sie, wägen sie gegeneinander ab
und fassen sie zusammen.
Sie veröffentlichen sogenannte
"Reviews", d.h.Studien über Studien.
Es gibt ein Cochrane Review über
Vitamin C und Erkältungen.
Und das ist sehr interessant.
Um verlässliche Daten zu bekommen,
hat man sich bei diesem Review
nur sogenannte
Kontrollierte Studien angeschaut.
Was heißt das? Stellt euch vor,
ihr seid Forscher und wollt testen,
ob Vitamin C
gegen Erkältungen hilft.
Dann reicht es nicht,dass ihr Leuten
einfach Vitamin C-Tabletten gebt
und schaut,ob es ihnen
besser geht, denn egal,
was in einer Tablette wirklich
drin ist, allein die Erwartung,
dass es mir durch diese Tablette
besser geht, kann dazu führen,
dass es mir wirklich besser geht.
Placebo-Effekt.
Deswegen braucht
die eine Kontroll-Gruppe.
Eine zweite Testgruppe,
denen ihr nur Placebos verabreicht.
Schein-Pillen ohne Vitamin C.
Und nur, wenn es
eurer Testgruppe mit Vitamin C
signifikant besser geht als der
Kontrollgruppe mit den Placebos,
nur dann ist Vitamin C wirksam.
Also merkt euch, wenn ihr
aussagekräftige Studien wollt,
braucht ihr kontrollierte Studien.
Es gibt einige kontrollierte
Studien, die untersucht haben,
ob Vitamin C Erkältungen vorbeugt.
Ob eine tägliche hohe Dosis
Vitamin C das Risiko verringert,
sich zu erkälten. Im Review
wurden 29 Studien zusammengefasst,
mit insgesamt
über 11.000 Teilnehmern.
Das sind viele, dass es statistisch
erst mal super, nur, ihr könnt jetzt
nicht einfach dieser Ergebnisse
dieser 29 Studien zusammen zählen,
durch 29 teilen und das war's. Denn
eine Studie mit wenigen Teilnehmern
und starker statistischer Streuung
hat weniger Aussagekraft als eine
andere Studie mit vielen Teilnehmern
und weniger statistischer Streuung.
Vielleicht hat die eine Studie
eine bestimmte Gruppe untersucht,
die nicht so gut vergleichbar sind
mit Teilnehmern anderer Studien,
deswegen müsste
eine "Metaanalyse" machen.
Bei der ihr die Ergebnisse
verschiedene Studien
sinnvoll gegeneinander
abwägt und gewichtet.
Ein gängiges Mittel
bei solchen Metaanalysen
ist der "Forrest Plot".
Manchmal auch Blommogram genannt.
Sagen wir, wir machen eine Meta-
analyse von 5 verschiedenen Studien.
Jede Studie hat untersucht,
ob das Erkältungsrisiko sinkt,
wenn man Vitamin C zu sich nimmt.
1 ist unser Referenzwert in
Studie eins hat man beobachtet,
dass das Risiko um die Hälfte sinkt.
Dann ist das Ergebnis 0,5 in Studie
2 war das Risiko ungefähr gleich.
Studie 3 hat einen verdoppeltes
Risiko gemessen, also 2 usw.
Jetzt ist jede Studie nur durch
einen Mittelwert dargestellt.
Wiederholt man dieselbe Studie
mit anderen Versuchsteilnehmern,
würde der Mittelwert etwas
weiter links oder rechts liegen.
Deswegen berechnet man für jede
Studie ein "Konfidenzintervall".
Statt eines Punktwerts
habe ich einen Balken.
Je kleiner das Konfidenzintervall,
desto sicherer kann ich mir
über den Mittelwert sein.
Je kürzer dieser Balken,
desto genauer ist mein Punkt,
wir sollten also nicht
schauen, wie die Punkte um
den Referenzlinie verteilt sind,son-
dern, wie die Balken verteilt sind.
Um das noch deutlicher zu machen,
macht man die Punkte mit
weniger Aussagekraft kleiner,
und die mit
großer Aussagekraft größer.
Und entsprechend muss man
diese verschiedenen Ergebnisse
verschieden stark gewichten. Am Ende
kommt man auf ein Gesamtergebnis.
Genau dasselbe hat man mit
diesen 29 Studien gemacht,
hier ist der "Forest Plot":
Lasst euch nicht irritieren
von diesen Pfeilen,
ein Pfeil ist
eine optische Abkürzung,
wenn der Federbalken zu
einer Seite hin keinen Platz hat,
müsst ihr euch die andere Hälfte
symmetrisch hinten dazu denken.
Fasst man alle Studien zusammen,
reduziert Vitamin C das Risiko,
sich zu erkälten
um gerade mal 0-6%.
Also:
Bei diesem Ergebnis sind
5 Studien nicht einbezogen,
die sind hier extra aufgeführt.
Denn bei diesen Studien hat man
keine 0815-Bevölkerung untersucht,
sondern sehr spezielle Gruppen,
die schlecht vergleichbar sind,
Marathonläufer, Skiläufer
und kanadische Soldaten in
einem subarktischen Einsatz.
Bei diesen Gruppen, mit akuter,
hoher körperlicher Belastung,
führte Vitamin C zu
einer deutlichen Verringerung
des Erkältungsrisikos.
Unterm Strich eine
Verringerung von 36-65%.
Die Skifahrer und die Soldaten,
das war jeweils nur eine Studie,
aber bei den Marathonläufen
waren es immerhin drei Studien,
also, liebe Marathonläufer wenn
man jetzt keinen Marathon läuft,
erkältet man sich nicht seltener,
aber, wenn es einen mal erwischt,
dann dauert die
Erkältung nicht so lange,
das fand man bei einer
weiteren Metaanalyse heraus.
Bei Erwachsenen verkürzte
sich die Erkältung um 8%,
bei Kindern sogar um 14%.
Fassen wir zusammen, viel Vitamin C
senkte nicht das Risiko,
sich zu erkälten, es sei denn,
man ist Marathonläufer.
Und eventuell auch Skifahrer
oder Soldat in der Subarktis.
Aber die Erkältung kann
sich verkürzen, außerdem fand man
bei keiner der Studien Nebenwirkung
von hohen Vitamin C-Dosen.
Wenn ihr Vitamin C-Junkies kennt,
schickt ihnen gerne dieses Video.
Ich muss es noch wissen,was mit euch
ist, nehmt ihr regelmäßig Vitamine,
oder andere
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel?
Und wenn ja, welche?
Verratet es mir unter dem #extra.
Unter demselben Hashtag könnte
auch generell Fragen stellen
zu Nahrungsergänzungsmitteln,
dazu werde ich in Zukunft
ein weiteres Video machen.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)